[Inaudible].
[Inaudible]
Latina also.
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] hammock. So
[inaudible].
And I take the pedestrian
[inaudible] here. He gives him this temperature to win deals.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
That's the first
[inaudible] lifted entrepreneur coast.
[inaudible] we had the
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] object also showed their room finished.
[inaudible] also
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] I
[inaudible] dude. I'm already a hammer hammer.
[Inaudible].
Well, they're the
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible].
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible] like, so, eh, I don't think it's on there.
[inaudible] Definitely. I used to that.
So I was [inaudible] someone out to bond
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] three [inaudible] and tell her. Yeah.
Oh
[inaudible] Oh,
[inaudible] [inaudible] never let this author book run the police.
They stole the sociology
[inaudible] group or the good enough for me
[inaudible] as a defense. You ankle
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] and stance. Oh, you're home in
to
[inaudible] yeah.
[inaudible] Linda Smith. The African time over to that.
Very clear African Cyanogen the remission not listed
[inaudible] interview that. So the
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] did the
[inaudible] take care of the
day after I talked about him. Me
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] that before
I go to
[inaudible] I'll do it in less than men scam.
[inaudible] [inaudible] that's referred this lesson.
[inaudible] I said [inaudible] audio lesson feel.
[Inaudible].
[Inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] they all take the right Zack.
[Inaudible] so, so you would do that for sure. How they leave
[inaudible].
[Inaudible] get them all for that.
[inaudible] we all fought response. [inaudible] did you do that?
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] uh, they make you float lit
[inaudible] thereby so
[inaudible].
Yeah, [inaudible] take it to that.
And y'all as a, okay, come on.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] contract for shutting anything. So the hub Bateson episode,
there are many Keisha molds.
Well they're [inaudible] uh,
[inaudible].
Are your Viagra color for premiere [inaudible].
[Inaudible].